[Music]
Nikki Bella gets real about where things
stand with her and ex-fiance John Cena I
lament my relationship it has been and
uh just a super emotional roller coaster
ride in a new promo for total Bella's
viewers watched the 34 year old WWE star
say yes to the dress I think this is it
but as we all know Nikki and John never
made it to the altar the two called off
their engagement three weeks before
there may fit the wedding date and I
think it's hard for people to understand
because we film and things get shown a
few months after and I think people are
like are there together are they are
they not in a new video posted to the
Bellas sister's YouTube channel
Nikki explains why what fans are seeing
on TV isn't the full story of her
relationship right now we're just
friends we are both working on each
other and trying to work on us and we
talk every day I do have hope for us and
John right now is in China filming a
movie and so it I hate to say perfect
timing but it's giving us this time in
life to see what we really want for the
future shortly after their split Nikki
echoed similar sentiments to et John
my wife and I truly hoped one day that
we could work it out and get back
together and John was sure to spread the
love - I love Nicole with all my heart
and that's that
[Music]
[Applause]